Oh
it's a good to be here after three years
last time I spoke at Stanford was seeing
2009 I'm really happy to see some of you
again you guys as young as three years
ago but I'm older I've got a lot more
gray hair than before especially in the
Internet age three years is a long time
a lot has happened and today I'm
supposed to talk about mobile let me
tell you something that happened in the
beginning of the year in our company you
know every company does an annual plan
budgeting for for the yearly results
right and we do that too at the
beginning of the year I had a debate
with our VP of engineering our mobile
KPI key that stands for key performance
indicator right so he insisted our
mobile revenue would grow 200 times 20%
times or triple for the year and I
insisted that's not enough the way we
try to achieve this is that you know for
for search the revenue is basically
decided by the number of queries or page
view and then the capability for you to
monetize for each page view or each
query so that's called CPM I had a
strong conviction that the the page view
would grow like a hundred fifty percent
so in order to achieve that triple in
revenue the CPM would only need to grow
around
twenty-five percent but I said 25
percent was not enough when when I had a
disagreement with my team members you
early my team members will prevail or I
will let them try their ideas first so I
said okay 25 percent for the whole year
right we were supposed to achieve a 25
percent growth in CPM for mobile search
three months later we achieved the 25
percent growth but now I realized okay
finally the age of mobile in the night
arrived and it has come a long way back
in 2002 I was in China and people
started to talk to me about mobile
internet about mobile search we asked me
Robin when I going to do a mobile search
or you they say they said to me you have
to do mobile search because China has X
hundred million of mobile phone users
the X started from 300 million then go
go to you know four hundred million 500
million 600 million the mobile phone
users could grow but mobile Internet
didn't come what came later was the so
called as people's service provider
business I think many of you know what
it means
many of the internet companies work with
the telecom carriers in China and became
their service provider and share revenue
for mobile services they provide to
their subscribers a lot of the company
actually almost all the major Internet
companies in China became profitable
because they did the SPD's companies
from $0.10 to Cena
- so who
Andie's you name it they were losing
money Lou they lost a lot of money in
the beginning of 2000 and after the
internet bubble bursted they couldn't
find anything that made money and then
this SP Vince came along and saved a lot
of the internet companies in China but I
just didn't believe in the the
expedience and reason is that
essentially I think the SP Dean's is the
relationship ins and your success or how
much money you make really depend on how
good your relationship is with the
mobile carriers or to be accurate it
depend on how good your relationship is
with the mobile carrier which is China
Mobile so that will be a dangerous means
if your bins relies so much on one
partner than anything could happen but
they made a lot of money that the
internet companies in China at that time
made a lot of money and at that time
Baidu was losing money so I also
struggled I I came back to Silicon
Valley I at that time I still had a
housing mountain view I sat in my car
and thought about what should we do but
after that I still concluded a
relationship business is not the
direction Baidu should go so I continue
to focus on search I mean Desktop Search
we didn't do anything unknowable for
quite a few years but after that as you
know that the SP business floundered and
the internet space Lenzi landscape
continued to change a lot has happened
since then the
Carrie opens became more competitive now
in China we have three major carriers
China Mobile China Telecom and China
Unicom they each will issued a 3G
license and the the best standard was
given to the weakest player at that time
the the most dominant player got a China
specific standard so there was policy
and enough competition in the caravans
then the iPhone was invented and Android
became popular later on then I realized
that okay
it's some is time for us to do something
in the mobile space but mobile is very
different from desktop in a lot of
senses if you look at the whole internet
space in China there are basically three
major categories in terms of revenue or
or nature of the business
the first is obviously advertising right
this is also a major business for the
rest of the world including the US when
people talk about internet that the
first thing they think about in terms of
business model is advertising and in
China that's a big bins - we are in that
bins but there are things that's China's
specific that's online games the online
games marketing China is larger than the
advertising the online advertising bins
so that's different but that's that's a
proven bins in China and the third major
Bin's model for the internet is
ecommerce supporting e-commerce
transactions on the internet there are
only three major bents models for the
internet and all of this business models
are challenged
on the mobile platform for for the
advertising business you probably
understand it easily the larger the
screen is the larger the revenue is
right for for the TV screen it's
probably the largest then a lot of the
revenue
I spend advertising revenue on or
advertising budget I spend on TV that's
true in China that's also true in the US
and for online advertising when you on a
desktop it's still okay it still
represents a large percentage of the
total online or the total advertising
market but when it comes to mobile
phones the screen is much smaller it's
very hard for you to put in a lot of ads
among the content so you can see that
from u.s. to China from display - to
search mobile advertising does not
commend the same magnified vision
capability as desktop internet so that's
for advertising and for online games
it's similar if you study the major game
companies in China from you know $0.10 -
to Shanda to naiis they they make most
of their money from online games but the
the games are mostly client-side games
were the so called MMORPG you have you
usually have to download a large package
of software on your desktop before
playing with the games it's very hard
for people to accept a smaller screen
less powerful computer
to do that so today both in the US and
in China games the mobile handsets are
much smaller businesses than the desktop
based games and then ecommerce right
today what we know that the e-commerce
company make most out their money or
transactions from the desktop computers
but on a mobile phone it has got started
but it's still a very small percentage
of the total ecommerce transactions and
people haven't really figured out what's
the best Vince to do to do the mobile
phones although it's very hard for us to
find the right way to monetize the
mobile Internet a lot of people are very
optimistic about the future of mobile
internet and us included so we not only
developed the best mobile web search we
also develop the best mobile browser
best mobile IME which stands for input
master engine that's not something you
need in the US but for non-english
languages Amy is very useful especially
for languages like Chinese or other
double byte characters you really need a
good input master engine we have the
best I mean we have a lot of apps that's
very popular many other companies also
try to develop a lot of apps and
distribute it through the phone
manufacturers who care
when you buy a phone in China I usually
come is a lot of apps pre-loaded and
many of the apps are not wanted by you
and sometimes it's even disturbing right
those apps could could send alerts to
you like an SMS so you are constantly
bothered by a lot of things that you
don't really want so I I want to ask you
how many of you know the term [ __ ] wow
that's a lot but there's probably not a
exact term in English try literally
means brush a machine it may be the
equivalent is the flash around right
well when you don't want it the
operating system that come with your
mobile phone you you try to ring start
with a an operating system that you like
and this is some big bins in China
there's a value chain theorem there are
developers who try to come up with a rom
that could be liked by the user then
there are distributors who will help
consumers to to flash your rom it's
going to be interesting to watch how
this this ecosystem will evolve right in
China this year along I was told about
150 million Android forms will be sold
right that's the largest marketing in
the world for Android phones already so
many phones are sold and the competition
is intense handset manufacturers have to
find ways to cover their cost
so they work with a lot of app
developers or distributors to preload a
lot of apps and those app developers or
or companies would generally pay two to
three one for each pre-loaded app and
the carrier's do that too
they also try to preload a lot of
unwanted apps on the cell phone to cover
their cost or to lower the cost of all
the consumers to get their phone so the
more unwanted apps you preload on the
phone
the higher the incentive for consumers
to flash you're wrong right so if a
large enough group of users start to
flash the ROM then it makes no sense for
the app developers to pay a lot of money
to preload this ass because they will be
gone anyway and before the app
developers can figure out a business
model they already spent a lot of money
and this money could be wasted because
the the ROM could be flashed and because
they cannot stay on the consumers mobile
phones the mobile phone manufacturers
and even carriers may not be able to
make enough money to cover their cost so
this could become a very dangerous
ecosystem so it's very important for us
to find the right business model for
mobile internet and I understand a lot
of people are trying but it's really not
clear at this time yet by doing cluded
we don't know we don't know which app
will become the killer
and which have well make the most money
for us but what we do know is that the
users loved mobile internet and we have
to go with them and we have to develop a
sense that they want over the past year
we have been worked working on a two
platform that supports the mobile
developers for Baidu our strengths is
really on the cloud side you know search
engine is essentially the the earliest
and most probably most sophisticated
cloud application in the Internet age
and because we worked on search for more
than 10 years we've accumulated a lot of
technology on the cloud side not only
that we also accumulated a lot of users
hundreds of millions of users and on the
Internet and we have a lot of data or
intelligence about our users so what we
could do is to offer our capability to
the mobile app developers the capability
including includes storage that the
computing power and the data
intelligence so earlier this month
during our annual event by the world we
revealed the so-called seven weapons for
the mobile developers that includes BAE
Baidu application engine PCs personal
storage service and screen X it's a tool
that allows an app to play on multiple
screens simultaneously and many others
and this tools are all free to the
developers so they can you
our platform use our storage use our
computing power for free to develop
their apps so we hope to form a vibrant
ecosystem for mobile apps based on the
infrastructure we have viewed and we
hope someday there will be a write app
for the mobile internet space by write
app I mean it's both popular and it's
got a business model people have forgot
that a popular app doesn't mean you are
be able to survive if you go back like
15 years ago you understand
Netscape was a very popular piece of
software but they were not able to
survive because they didn't have the
right things model after that you know a
lot of company failed during the
internet bubble in year 2000 but today
when you ask all the enterpreneurs
especially in China when you ask them
about their plans or when you ask them
how do you how would you make money they
would generally answer all I don't care
they would say okay I'll first try to
get enough number of users but enough
number of users really means enough
number of cost doesn't necessarily mean
enough amount of money right so I think
we are at this dangerous juncture that a
lot of people are rushing into the
mobile space but we have yet able being
able to figure out how this ecosystem
will be sustained
I know in the u.s. that most people
think at or advertising it's the way to
go but we know that the monetization
capabilities for Google and Facebook and
many other companies their CPM on PC is
we higher than the mobile phone but in
China there are lots of companies that
does things very differently and online
game is a typical example but they can
charge the consumers directly so for
mobile internet this this pre charge or
subscription-based business could become
very popular because otherwise you would
not be able to make money and this
ecosystem will not be able to survive
right we have a background of
advertising we studied the the mobile
advertising a lot search is still very
effective and the CPM could grow
dramatically but other than search the
CPM could is very low and we don't have
any good insight on how to improve that
so that post a lot of challenge to the
whole internet world to the whole
landscape everyone has to think hard
about what should we do for the mobile
Internet China
country no as you know that a lot of
things are at a larger scale then it is
in the US
Baidu probably answers more query in
China than Google does in the US and
when there's something that's hot or
that's popular a lot of people a lot of
interviewers well rushing into it the
group buying phenomenon last year was
the typical example and the result for
that is that services in China generally
get better and better and become more
competitive hearing in this country if
you want five gigabyte of online storage
space you are probably need to pay a
subscription fee but in China the
standard offering for Baidu is a 15
gigabyte and you can get up to 100
gigabyte of free space as I mentioned
before that we offer computing power we
will offer storage we offer user we
offer a lot of tools for the mobile
developers and that's all for free
and the reason we're doing this is
because we think the market will
eventually figure things out figure out
how do we make money right if you cannot
make money based on advertisement the
developers will eventually start to
charge the consumers otherwise this
market wouldn't wouldn't exist so people
are very dependent on their mobile
phones now so they will have to pay
either ways
or they'll have to pay a subscription
fee or they all have to watch or read an
ad we just don't know which direction
will be the most popular one going
forward because China has a large crowd
has a large user base and because the
competition is very intense I do expect
a lot of the innovation will come from
China going forward when I started by
due back 12 years ago people constantly
talk about the Chinese Internet
this model is surely it's all about c2c
copy to China now it's changing because
we have a very large base now the
internet population in China is larger
than the US right whenever an app or
service comes up you will need to at
least reach a scale of 100 million
subscribers in order to really survive
but once you reach that scale survival
wouldn't be a big problem
but how do you really strive become
really successful that's a different
story for this kind of skill it's very
possible for us to encounter a new
problem before the u.s. encounters right
and I believe that innovation URI comes
from problem solving if you are able to
encounter a problem before anyone else
chances are that you will be able to
solve that problem and the moment you
stop the problem you make some
innovations
and that's why we are very hopeful about
the future of China's internet
especially the mobile internet space
because we do have I don't know 600
millions 700 million mobile users and
they will be using smartphones very soon
so they will carry an Internet terminal
24 hours and they will be able to demand
things that was not demanded elsewhere
in the world and we as the developers
and service providers of the internet
space will be able to solve their
problems first and innovate so I
encourage everyone of you with the China
more and get a better sense of this
market if you have interest to go to
China to do business I think that's it
that would be a good decision there is a
good chance you will be able to find
opportunities that you cannot find here
in the US that's all I have for today
thank
Robin said he'd be happy to take some
questions if you want to queue up with
the microphones you can choose who you'd
like to hi I'm from East Asian Studies
department at Stanford I have a few
quite odd basically one one question
about the perceived feature sizes of by
dual-core microphone okay I have a
question about your perceived feature
size for the Internet
I mean mobile internet searching engines
in the future because I think this is
actually changing the business model for
on a on a very significant level in
terms of basically right now a bit
before before the mobile internet
basically Baidu was successful because
of the site and yet right now when we're
actually using iPhones for example it is
the small apps that solve in big
problems or even small problems that we
really want and for the users we're
interested in having something that
basically cost like nothing and can
solve some practical problems and for a
small company that are basically just
interested in solving solving one or two
problems they're very capable of having
a few people and make a very successful
app that can sustainably have some
subscribers but I'm not sure you know
how up I do perceive itself as having
partnerships with small businesses and
especially those independent ones who
might have no interest of competing with
Baidu but not necessarily have interests
of of cooperating with with you
Thanks okay um that's a good question
first of all you correctly pointed out
that there's a challenge for mobile
search on the desktop search is the
widely regarded as the the Gateway to
the internet for most of the users but
people start from a search box then go
elsewhere to
gets their needs fulfilled but on the
mobile phone based on our our statistics
about 80% of the media time is spent on
apps and only 20% spending a browser and
if browser is no longer the the
mainstream software for people to access
the Internet on the mobile phone then
search would have a problem what we
working on is try to integrate the
content with apps starting from 2009 we
initiated a concept called box computing
which means you can type in anything you
want in the search box in the search box
does not only return content it can also
return data returned and apps or the
search box could become a command line
you can type in whatever you want and
we'll try to satisfy you
so on the mobile phone that's even more
important we wanted to become the
de-facto gateway or starting point for
our Internet users by integrating both
apps and and content so today if you try
our search on a mobile phone you will be
able to find a lot of apps certified
safe so you can download quickly but
that's just too the first step we're
working on is to try to satisfy user's
needs by figuring a smarter way to index
those two apps so that the consumers or
users not only confine those apps by the
name of the app but also by the meaning
by the content within the app so we try
to become the Gateway for mobile phone
users to and once we achieve that that
status we will be able to distribute
apps for a lot of smart developers right
now the a-star model is flawed it's very
difficult for small developers to to
find their way to reach the targeted
consumers and we believe by providing a
better search engine which means that
the search engine can buy both the
content and apps consumers will
increasingly use our search box to find
things they want including those apps
once we achieve that we think we will be
able to present a lot more opportunities
for the smaller apps and I do think that
would be the future because the only way
for you to make a very vibrant ecosystem
is to allow those long tail smaller
developers to to strive and search did
this for webmasters in the desktop age
and we hope to do this I do hope to do
this for the app developers seen in the
mobile age - so not only we allow people
to do - typing query words we also have
the best attorneys language recognition
system that you can you can talk to the
phone and do it whatever you want
so going forward if that becomes the
main gateway developers will be able to
find their way you know to the targeted
consumers yeah okay just question about
your mobile strategy so just look at the
dispute between Alibaba and Google just
Google - Stan are you operating system
adopted Google Android's environment
infrastructure and tools but might they
are even can be compatible with the
current Google Android platform so the
things also
the same to Baidu so you know we
operating system just adopted the
original it came from the Android
infrastructure and tools and environment
and you just put your read redesign your
UI and it just put all your apps on the
platform and you also wanted to
cooperate with the Google and Joyce OHA
partners just like down so with this
kind of the case the the odd-even case
will bring some negative impact on your
mobile approach in the future it seems
you know in Google and Baidu is doing a
very sensitive relation right yeah I
think what we're trying to do is try to
satisfy our users needs better
that could mean a better web search or a
better browser or a better
yiii or a better operating system right
now the Baidu we operating system is
based on Android it's fully compatible
with the Android system but we did a lot
of things that made the user experience
better it's it's a young customized
system and we work with a lot of handset
manufacturers I think the market will
eventually decide whether that's the
right approach we spend a lot of time to
study our users and try to come up with
innovations to satisfy their users the
users needs we don't try to reinvent the
wheel if something is already good
enough we don't have to modify that but
I think the mobile internet is still in
its infant stage there are still a lot a
lot of things that's not optimal yet and
lots of requests lots of needs have not
been met by the existing system so we're
working on things like that we hope to
to be able to better satisfy the Chinese
users needs by all kinds of offerings
from Baidu how much of your total R&D
now is going towards mobile versus
desktop so if you can talk a little bit
about the shift specifically in R&D
spending and and how that spending is
you know where that spending is going
from desktop to mobile and then when
should we expect mobile to become a
material business and I guess material
could mean anything a few percent 10%
what are we talking you know one year
three years five years how far out are
you looking right now about 25% of our
resources are devoted to mobile and that
number is subject to change it could
change next month could change next
quarter or could change next year
because the market keep changing so we
have to constantly re-evaluate our
resource allocation but right now the
number is about 25% of course the
revenue from mobile is much less than
that and although it's growing very fast
as I mentioned in the beginning of the
talk the revenue at least to triple this
year but it's still like a single-digit
contribution to the total revenue
exactly one it will become a more
material revenue source I don't know I'm
in no hurry to figure that out because
we know that there are a lot of room for
improvement for the mobile cp/m so we'll
continue to work on that we are like I
mentioned we are developing an
infrastructure to support a lot of
mobile app developers so that they can
run their apps on our servers we hope to
figure out a bit smaller later on from
that yet but that's probably a at least
a three year you know timeline for any
revenue or profit I have a question
about your core business you've got a
new challenge from Qi who 360 recently
and I'm just wondering on the on the
desktop search at this point is
innovation slowed down is it going to be
easier for competitors to catch up to
you and what are you doing to innovate
further and and expand your lead um I've
been working on the search engine for
many many years
and I firmly believe whoever can provide
the best user experience will be able to
win the market for search surgery is a
very complicated matter you have to
devote a lot of R&D resources and be
very focused in order to come up with
the best search quality we have a huge
lead over many almost all of the
competitors in terms of search quality
and we will continue to devote more
resources especially Rd resources thing
to the Chinese language search so we
believe a longer term users will still
come to the best quality search engine
wherever that is in China or elsewhere
it's just sometimes certain distribution
channel could command a small percentage
of search traffic but that's that's not
going to become a really competing
product to me I say cup you can find
distribution distribution channels here
and there but it's at the end of day
it's the search quality that well that
will drive most of the Internet users to
a search engine
thank you sort of following up on that
same question is there anything
different about 360 versus the other
competitors that you've previously faced
you know successfully in the market and
secondly from that you know how do you
think about the runway remaining in you
know core desktop search obviously you
know the growth opportunity they're on
yeah I think Bob they are compared
that focused on search quality and there
are sometimes competitors sometimes
partners that focus on channel or
distribution for example the the telecom
carriers was that important distribution
channel for our search and some of them
still are they have their value in the
in the value chain sometimes we choose
to work with them sometimes they choose
to work with someone else and compete
with us I think that's okay at the end
of day again if we can provide the best
user experience we'll be able to win win
the market I think time is up you want
to take one more or you're finished one
more please okay one more okay so my
name is Ivy I'm Angie he's got attacked
at any time soft side okay I'm from
squat education so we've talked a lot
about the business and technical issues
so I'm wondering like how do you see the
social value created by Baidu in China
and also like what kind of social impact
we want to make in the future
we took a different approach from many
of the US counterparts in terms of
social back in 2003 we launched a
product called called tea about post bar
it's probably the first web 2.0 product
before the term web 2.0 was coined in
the u.s. today it represents more than
10% of our total traffic and tens of
millions of users log on to enjoy on
this online community or in today's term
social the way it works that whenever
you tapping a query not only we show you
a list of web search results we also
show you a bar that allows people who
type in same query to exchange ideas
that's a very popular product in China
after that we also launched by do knows
by doing cyclopædia
and quite a few other social products so
today the traffic for Baidu social
product actually surpassed the traffic
for web search so we have a very strong
social product right now it's just again
what's the right business model for
social in the past the the social
products for Baidu
was really designed to help users to to
better find information to stay on Baidu
to use our web search more but going
forward there might be a good model for
this social products to just make money
by themselves we are studying that and
we are also hopeful because our social
products are generally interest based
it's it's relatively easier to deliver a
space based on users interest rather
than demographic information so we think
our social products is more valuable
than the typical social networks in
other companies